[Music]
every week at this time
we're going to be bringing you some of
the top tunes from the hit parade charts
all across the country
did you know that alex trebek was once
canada's answer
to dick clark he was the host of
musichop back in the early 60s
it was the beginning of something
special all right players time's up
let's find out who today's jeopardy
champion
is that was alex's very first ever final
jeopardy
it was 1984 but far from the first time
he appeared on tv
hello my name is trebek it used to be
close up
then this hour has seven days this is
the ontario native back in the 60s
auditioning for the canadian broadcast
company
welcome again to reach for the top after
beginning as a journalist he found his
calling as a game show host in both
english
and french
[Music]
success nice to have you joining us on
high rollers let's get right to it
in the 70s hollywood came calling and
alex's easygoing style got him job after
job
hi ladies and gentlemen and welcome once
again to classic concentrations
welcome once again to our game of
knowledge and nerve double dare it's
time now to find out
which of these ladies is really related
to the three stooges
[Music]
once he got the job of a lifetime he
found his home in 2014
alex broke bob barker's record for
hosting the most episodes of a single
game
show oh we're gonna get into it are we
at the time that was 6829 episodes
and with his own unique brand of humor
alex was humble
about the milestone they've had the good
fortune to be associated with a program
like jeopardy i've been around a long
[Music]
time